the upcoming prey has been described by
its developer arkane studios as a
spiritual successor to system shop from
what we've played so far it has the
potential of living up to such lofty
comparisons prey emphasizes exploration
and using weapons beyond your pistol and
shotgun like the immobilizing glucan and
while you're being hunted by
shape-shifting aliens you'll have the
opportunity to gain extraterrestrial
powers yourself like releasing energy
blasts and mimicking inanimate objects
what influences do you hope pray take
some system shots let us know in the
discussion blog while you're here give
us a thumbs up and subscribe to our
channel for more pray coverage thanks
for watching
[Music]
[Music]
here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what's happening don't let them do this
Jesus feel do you remember the first
time you said it was like you were
outside yourself like time itself at
bended knee waiting for you to decide
you moved my chair without touching it
gave me chills possibilities you became
something new that day something higher
I knew them as I believe now our mission
is to lift up all humanity in this same
weight hello
[Music]
vital signs
[Music]
[Music]
hey hey over here
research complete
[Music]
what you need guns ammo I sold him sighs
types going to that armory saw him
punching the code you get me out of here
i'll let you have it my name is Aaron
Aaron Ingram
come on now god damn it let me out
y'all really [ __ ] and fell backwards in
it huh
[Music]
hey what are you reading a rap sheet huh
look I'm telling you all my mama's grave
that is a stack of lies meant to make
pushing that button easier on you okay
fine listen I want to be honest some of
it probably is true I done some wrong in
my days with this ain't right now come
on y'all got to let me out of here I
never did anything those kids I was just
getting them out of a bad spot that's
all now the real criminals they didn't
like how it was chipping away at their
pile of rubles they got their claws sunk
deep into government now that's what I'm
talking about some human beasts friend
[Music]
gone now
[Music]
you
[Music]